i
2020 fue considerado el año de la
bicicleta en bogotá una de las ciudades
latinoamericanas con mayor uso de este
medio con casi un millón de viajes
diarios antes de la pandemia en el
último año el 13 por ciento de los
viajes en bogotá se hicieron en
bicicleta miles de personas han elegido
este medio de transporte durante la
crisis sanitaria para evitar las
aglomeraciones en el transporte público
pero también como un medio más
sostenible económico o para ejercitarse
durante los confinamientos la capital
colombiana cuenta con la cicloruta con
más kilómetros de américa latina' y fue
creada en 1974 además ha sido pionera en
la ampliación de ciclo infraestructura
durante la emergencia sanitaria y ya
cuenta con 588 kilómetros de ciclorrutas
permanentes y 46 kilómetros de ciclovías
temporales según la secretaria de
movilidad el caso más importante fue la
famosa carrera 7a una de las principales
arterias de bogotá el uso de la
bicicleta en ese corredor creció un 40
por ciento aumentando la percepción de
seguridad gracias a la implementación de
un carril segregado para los ciclistas
los hombres jóvenes de estratos bajos
son los principales usuarios de la
bicicleta como medio de transporte
y las mujeres representan tan sólo el 23
por ciento
por ello bogotá tiene como meta alcanzar
la paridad y unas condiciones más
seguras e inclusivas
[Música]
la falta de turistas y la falta de
tráfico debido a la pandemia han
impulsado todavía más el uso de la
bicicleta aquí en la ciudad de nueva
york son muchos los newyorkinos que han
elegido ir sobre dos ruedas en vez de
utilizar el metro porque se sienten más
seguros y es algo de entender sobre todo
en una ciudad como nueva york que es
bastante plana y hay cerca de 2.200
kilómetros habilitados para transcurrir
en bicicleta pero este boom ciclista ya
comenzó en los años 90 que fue cuando
comenzaron a instalarse los primeros
carriles para moverse en bicicleta bien
pues las cifras se han multiplicado
todavía más durante la pandemia para que
se hagan una idea durante el mes de
marzo del 2020 un millón 86 mil viajes
se hicieron con las bicicletas de
citibank que deberían estar aquí detrás
de mí pero como les digo están siendo
muy utilizadas cada vez más y como ven
ya casi no quedan bicicletas pues bien
durante el mes de septiembre esa cifra
casi se duplica a 2 millones 500 mil
viajes
solamente en 30 días
[Música]
voy a comprar una bicicleta por estos
días en parís es misión imposible el
vehículo a dos ruedas de un boom
extraordinario gracias a la pandemia el
año pasado el tráfico de bicicletas de
la ciudad aumentó en un 67 por ciento
sobre todo personas que no querían tomar
el transporte público para no
contagiarse de kobe 19 la ciudad puso en
marcha unas ciclovías de urgencia las
por una pista 60 kilómetros que se van a
volver perennes a partir de julio de
este año esto encaja perfecto con el
proyecto que tiene la alcaldesa han
hidalgo de hacer de parís una ciudad de
los 15 minutos y de eliminar de la
ciudad de aquí al año 2030 los autos a
combustión pero no es sólo la ciudad
también la región de parís bill de fos
creó 650 kilómetros de pistas de
urgencia como la que ustedes ven a mis
espaldas que lleva al centro de negocios
de la defensa en las afueras de parís de
estas pistas 5 se van a volver perennes
también una en la periferia con el
centro de la ciudad y son una
alternativa a los trenes de cercanías
tanto la ciudad como la región dan 600
dólares a sus ciudadanos para la
adquisición de una bicicleta